And how about the oil, gas and mining companies?
Okay, maybe it's a bit of a cliché to talk about them.
Corruption in that sector, no surprise.
There's corruption everywhere, so why focus on that sector?
Well, because there's a lot at stake.
In 2011, natural resource exports
outweighed aid flows by almost 19 to one
in Africa, Asia and Latin America. Nineteen to one.
Now that's a hell of a lot of schools and universities
and hospitals and business startups,
many of which haven't materialized and never will
because some of that money has simply been stolen away.
Now let's go back to the oil and mining companies,
and let's go back to Dan Etete and that $1 billion deal.
And now forgive me, I'm going to read the next bit
because it's a very live issue, and our lawyers
have been through this in some detail
and they want me to get it right.
Now, on the surface, the deal appeared straightforward.
Subsidiaries of Shell and Eni
paid the Nigerian government for the block.
The Nigerian government transferred
precisely the same amount, to the very dollar,
to an account earmarked for a shell company
whose hidden owner was Etete.
Now, that's not bad going for a convicted money launderer.
And here's the thing.
After many months of digging around
and reading through hundreds of pages of court documents,
we found evidence that, in fact,
Shell and Eni had known that the funds
would be transferred to that shell company,
and frankly, it's hard to believe they didn't know
who they were really dealing with there.
Now, it just shouldn't take these sorts of efforts
to find out where the money in deals like this went.
I mean, these are state assets.
They're supposed to be used for the benefit
of the people in the country.
But in some countries, citizens and journalists
who are trying to expose stories like this
have been harassed and arrested
and some have even risked their lives to do so.
And finally, well, there are those who believe
that corruption is unavoidable.
It's just how some business is done.
It's too complex and difficult to change.
So in effect, what? We just accept it.
But as a campaigner and investigator,
I have a different view,
because I've seen what can happen
when an idea gains momentum.
In the oil and mining sector, for example,
there is now the beginning
of a truly worldwide transparency standard
that could tackle some of these problems.
In 1999, when Global Witness called
for oil companies to make payments on deals transparent,
well, some people laughed at the extreme naiveté
of that small idea.
But literally hundreds of civil society groups
from around the world came together
to fight for transparency,
and now it's fast becoming the norm and the law.
Two thirds of the value
of the world's oil and mining companies
are now covered by transparency laws. Two thirds.
So this is change happening.
This is progress.
But we're not there yet, by far.
Because it really isn't about corruption
somewhere over there, is it?
In a globalized world, corruption
is a truly globalized business,
and one that needs global solutions,
supported and pushed by us all, as global citizens,
right here.
Thank you.
(Applause)